[Music]
how do we accurately identify and
address the sources of our depression
when it's not an obvious concern like
lack of money or friends
you know pete i think that the source
of the depression is never the source
right it is often
there's a source beneath the source like
the lack of money is not actually what's
causing me to be depressed it
and i know this from from personal
experience i grew up really poor and
thought we were unhappy growing up
because we didn't have money and so of
course when i
went out my 20s and climbed the
corporate ladder and started making
really good money
i was in a way even more depressed
because money simply amplified the
habits and behaviors
that were going on
before the you know the money right and
so there was something else beneath the
lack of money the other one was what
lack of of of friends right well
sometimes you can be surrounded by all
the friends that are making you
miserable or depressed and so
that's not the that's not the answer
either it seems to me there's always
some sort of
why behind the what yes yes and and
locating that is very difficult this is
why
right this is my critique by the way of
um
uh
too much drugs and meditation i'm not
against drugs and meditation
but when they're used as a way to
somehow access the deeper part of
yourself i've again i'm not even against
that so much but here's the issue that i
have with it is in psychoanalysis
there's this idea that who you are isn't
somewhere deep within it's on the
surface like you don't have to go deep
within the fact you you find who the
person is through just listening
carefully to what they say so in
psychoanalysis the reason is you have
you have a person
because
what you do is you start to
through projection and transference you
start to treat them in particular ways
and the way you treat them
helps them see
what you're doing what what's what's
going on in your life like it's almost
like
we can't see not because it's too deep
it's because it's so in our face like
it's everywhere so in like i'll give an
example a friend of mine recently said
um she wrote a text and she said i have
to send such and such a vice meal and
she meant voicemail which said vice mail
and um
what what that revealed you know if
whenever you listen literally it's going
oh she she is attracted to this guy she
wants to to have a sexual encounter with
him now that was not admitted at a
conscious level but that that freudian
slip
led to you know that understanding this
happens all the time is that we're
always telling the truth in our little
slips and all our little things and if
you just listen to
the slips you can begin to kind of like
work out what you're dealing with maybe
for example every time you're going to
see your mum you lose the keys you can't
find the keys to your car maybe you
don't want to see your mum right so
the
it's this is why i'm a big fan of
psychotherapy as some extent is that we
are invested in not seeing what makes us
we're invested in covering over things
so it requires a real sensitivity to
either having someone who feeds back
what we are to ourselves and helps us
see this
or if you don't have that you just keep
a really close eye on your dreams and on
your symptoms and on what you do and
don't do and you can begin like it's
like colombo i'm a big fan of colombo
like you're a detective to yourself you
have to be a detective to yourself like
the crime is being committed and there
are all of these little hints at what
the issue is and you have to be colombo
and you have to walk in and go okay
right i love my brother but i had this
real dream where my brother died like
well it's your dream like so you drowned
him
maybe i've got an issue with my brother
oh that's weird i didn't think i had an
issue with my brother but i did dreamly
drowned so again you're listening
to things or an example
of i had to meet a friend and went to
the wrong coffee shop with a different
name and i realized once i got there
oh yeah i know that other coffee shop
why did i go to this coffee shop half an
hour away right oh i don't want to see
them and they've got oh right so you
listen why did i forget to see my kids
or was it because you know like i love
my kids but but i didn't go and see them
so i cuz i forgot maybe it's because i
want my kids to hate me because i hate
myself you know the truth is always
operating around you and when you talk
about dreams it can be literal dreams
but also like what do you fantasize
about what do you daydream about what
are your desires both conscious and
unconscious
and and where do they emanate from
because what you're really talking about
here is getting to the bottom of that
now
as you said some sort of expert can sort
of hold up a mirror
and it's not about going to a therapist
because quite often what do we do we go
there and say all right give me
the prescription either literally if we
go to a doctor fix me right now i can't
sleep i need the pill to sleep
i am depressed i need the pill to not be
depressed and it's not to say there
isn't a use for
prescription or or pharmacological
solutions
but
usually the solution ends up just
becoming another problem that layers on
top of the existing problem it covers up
the problem yes absolutely and we can
sometimes depression is interesting
because sometimes depression arises from
as we talked about in the podcast a
failure of desire between we can no
longer desire we find ourselves no
longer desiring or we're fixated we we
desire one thing we're desire one person
or one thing we can't move beyond that
there's that fixated desire
and so sometimes once you isolate the
depression and and kind of where it's
coming from say you're fixated on a
person um
the problem is basically again i forget
that this is before the podcast we
talked about signifiers but um
uh
signifying chian is stopped whenever
you're fixated on someone someone stands
in for the thing they are the real thing
that will fix everything and be
everything and we have to kind of
very slowly realize that they're not
like even if you your life could have
been better with that person for example
it wouldn't have been perfect because
they are not the thing that will satisfy
and complete you
and sometimes partly it's um
we get over a fixation by
coming to that realization and and then
our desire continues to function and
then we can start desiring somebody else
somebody new
so um but yeah depression is usually is
a function of a failure of desire either
desire is stopped pretty much or it's
fixated it's stuck on something and um
uh
yeah that's and we all i think that's
different times experience that to some
extent for sure and
and we may
we may stop desiring and feel like
there's something wrong with me or we
may desire something that is
impossible based on you we've set up
some story that we tell ourselves some
expectation that that we have
established and it's leading us to
misery and eventually spiraling out of
control and no wonder we're depressed
and you mentioned other people they
become the objects of our desire and yes
while your life may have been better if
you had been with that person or you had
gotten that job the only reason it would
be better
is because i've told myself the story
that now my life is is better right it's
the same with your life is worse but by
the people you surround yourself with no
not really no one really has the power
to upset you
you have the power to upset you although
it feels as though we've set up this
strange superpower with all of our
friends and family and loved ones and
neighbors and even perfect strangers on
the street one little caval from someone
can send us into a spiral of depression
because of the expectation of i need
their respect i need their appreciation
i need them to think of me in this
particular light and if they don't then
the story i'm going to tell myself is
well my life would be better if they
would and the great the thing is which
is is your life by definition wouldn't
be better with that person for one
reason that because they've become
a fantasized object an ideal so i had a
great experiment that was play night in
reality for me as i had two friends
one who was obsessed with this person
and
they were both obsessed with with
somebody one of them they didn't end up
with that person the other they did so
it was really fun because they were had
very similar lives one ended up with
this with this this girl he wanted to be
with the other didn't and
what was that and both were tragic at
first right so the person who didn't
they had to get over their fixation and
so with a psychoanalysis and the person
who did they ended up just fighting it
was so destructive and actually that was
even worse because both of them this was
the object that would bring satisfaction
and completeness so either you're
between a rock and a hard place you're
unhappy because you don't get it or
you're unhappy because you do but um
both of them had to learn
that there is nothing that stops up all
desire and and yeah and actually getting
the thing can often be the worst of the
two because it it eliminates the desire
the very thing that made you feel alive
and so getting everything you ever
wanted is often the biggest cause of
depression yes or everything you thought
you wanted because it turns out often
that everything you ever wanted isn't
actually what you wanted at all
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free